I always be like school choice week it's
like one of the rare occasions where we
have an event at reason that's mostly
good news like we're attend to we tend
to hold these events that are like the
economy is a disaster the political
process is faster so it's really nice to
have this event where it's like everyone
puts on your cute yellow scarves and
we're like school choice is winning I
think there was a story that's been
going around facebook today that really
encapsulates kind of the spirit of
school choice and this actually is about
these parents that are camping out in
Shelby County Tennessee in the freezing
cold to get their kids a spot in the
school of their choice and I guess this
district in tennessee has like some kind
of options program where only a certain
number of kids can sign up and you have
to be there in person so they're
actually camping out now for a decision
that's going to be decided in on Monday
and so like one of the woman's the one
of the women that they interviewed she's
number 38 in line right to get her kid a
spot in school and she's planning on
like sleeping in a tent in front of the
school district until Monday so she can
get her kid in a school now as a school
choice advocate I'm not sure that I
would even work that hard for my own kid
but it's commendable and it goes to kind
of the fact that in the United States
the demand for school choice really
exceeds the available spots and even so
there's way more school choice than
there was 20 years ago and today the
milton friedman foundation for
educational choice published their
annual abc's of school choice and they
came out with some new numbers on how
much school choice is really growing in
the united states and you know it's it's
interesting because officially vouchers
and tax credits so vouchers you get it's
like a pell grant you get an amount of
money that you can pick the school of
your choice and tax credits you either
get to keep your own money or you get
some rich person's money or some other
person's money to send your kid to
school but
those programs like 10 years ago really
Milwaukee was the only school choice
program in the United States and it had
about seven thousand kids and so today
we actually have over 300,000 kids that
are using either a tax credit or a
voucher to send their kids to school and
there are some notable programs that
I'll just read you a couple numbers so
Florida actually has the largest tax
credit scholarship program in the
country and they have 60,000 kids that
are using tax credits to go to the
school of their choice private school
they have almost 30,000 kids that are in
a special needs scholarship program
where if they have a special education
designation they can then use the amount
of money that would have gone to their
special education to go to any school of
their choice in the state Indiana is
interesting because it has a new school
choice program that now has 20,000 kids
it's only in the second year and it's
one of the only voucher programs in the
country where it's not completely
restricted to low income kids and some
middle-income kids can go Pennsylvania
has 30,000 kids using tax credits
Arizona has what's called an education
savings account and that's pretty
interesting because the whole per-pupil
amount actually works like a medical
savings account where it goes into the
parents discretion into an account and
they can use it not just for a school
but for any kind of education expenses
and then the money rolls over so if you
don't use all of the per pupil allotment
that's in your education savings account
you can apply it towards college or
maybe you don't use all the money in
elementary school but you want to pick a
more expensive high school education so
you know so these education savings
accounts started out they were only for
special education kids or foster care
kids and now they've expanded the
program to be any low-income kids that
are in failing schools and every year
they're planning on expand
the program so education savings account
a completely new model that didn't exist
a few years ago there's six thousand
charter schools with 2.2 million kids
and people like to talk about charter
schools like they're really some kind of
marginal reform but if you think about
it charter schools work exactly like
voucher schools they're open enrollment
you only get the per pupil allotment if
the parents choose the schools and
there's 2.2 million kids in charter
schools and a million kids in waiting
lists and charter schools are
interesting because they politically
have been more feasible because you
don't have to have a statewide
initiative fight with the teachers
unions over you know should we have a
voucher program or a tax credit they've
been much more stealth because they've
been able to get one charter school or
three charter schools approved at a time
and then what's happened is you have
cities like Los Angeles or New Orleans
New Orleans has a hundred percent of
their kids enrolled in charter schools
now they're going to become the
first-ever all charter school district
and their scores have really been
through the roof they used to be ranked
second to last in the state of Louisiana
for the test scores and they've actually
gone up I think 40 spots in the last
five years so there I think 33rd or
something like that in the state in
terms of districts but they went out of
like 90-something districts they went
from dead last to 33rd their graduation
rates and test scores have improved
rapidly Los Angeles has lost two hundred
thousand kids to charter schools and
they have only they have over 200
charter schools within the geographic
area of Los Angeles so there's places
like cleveland detroit washington DC los
angeles where the market share of
charter schools and where the money
follows the kids and the kids select the
schools based on their you know parents
investigation and choice is really
growing and the teachers unions really
know that the other notable thing about
the charter school movement is theirs
it's really where there's been room
for innovation so not only is New
Orleans known for giving kids choice
they've had all these kinds of
interesting you know apps and
innovations and technology to help kids
in New Orleans because they're able to
try because they don't have the normal
restrictions bureaucracy rules and they
can get around those rules so they've
called also New Orleans the kind of
Silicon Valley of education in terms of
experimentation and there's a lot going
on with technology in terms of blended
learning in flipped classrooms and I
know Catherine's going to talk about
technology a little bit and give you the
details and then the final thing that
all say is because of all this choice
one of the things that Katie and I have
been studying is urban school districts
have decided to give their own students
choice and autonomy to their principles
and they've actually started having kind
of market education environments within
their school district where they let the
money follow the child and they let the
principal's make decisions about the
money and katie is going to talk a
little more about that and so I would
just like to conclude with the fact that
compared to 20 years ago we have a lot
more school choice we have a lot further
to go but lots of indicators whether its
technology charter schools vouchers the
way the teachers unions are reacting
point to a future where parents really
are going to keep demanding choice
they're never going to go back they're
going to sleep in tents but hopefully
someday they won't have to they'll be
able to have choices without camping out
for you know a weekend in the cold this
weekend of the year and on that note
Katie you want to talk about some of the
public schools reactions to school
choice yeah sure um so I'm going to tell
you a little bit about a whole kind of
nuanced take on school choice that is
district-wide and I think 15 school
districts nationwide I've actually
adopted this and some people call it
school funded port up school funding
portability it's also known as
backpacking or weighted student formula
there's a lot of different names for
this particular school finance policy
which sounds really wonky and kind of
boring but I promised it is kind of cool
um so what weighted student formula is
is a school district sends rather than
funding schools will fund students and
money follows a child to the school of
their choice in traditional school
districts schools are usually funded by
funding like teaching positions and
staff student ratios and there's a
usually a huge equity gap from school to
school depending on what the finance
policy is so this is more equitable when
it and it funds students on a per pupil
basis to a school of their choice so
school choice is a huge part of this
kind of equation along with several
other kind of components that work
together one way to make it make way to
student formula more equitable is that
districts will have a base amount for a
student and then they'll have several
other weights that are tacked on to that
base so for example in Hartford
Connecticut there's a base amount of
money that each kid gets and then on top
of that they'll give kids extra money
for if they're an English language
learner or if they're special needs if
they're gifted and then that money
follows down then to the school that
they choose or their parents choose and
so going hand in hand with that that
kind of creates like a market mechanism
so schools can want to attract more
students to them and then they get to
also get the money that follows them to
the schools so principal should have
more autonomy over that money and to
make their schools more attractive right
markets and you know demand and
everything so that's another huge
component of it so with weighted student
formula principals have a much larger
piece of the budget that they have
autonomy over one finding in our
weighted student formula yearbook that
Lisa and Iowa worked on was that schools
that have our school districts that have
a larger portion of but of the budget
that goes directly to principles that
principals can have you know full
autonomy over those school districts
usually have higher proficiency rates
they increase their proficiency faster
and there is much smaller achievement
gaps in those
in those districts also schools with
weighted sewer districts with weighted
student formula they have a ton the
prism principals have autonomy over
hiring and usually they'll have a little
bit more wiggle room with unions and
trying to negotiate school contracts and
that type of thing another in exchange
for a lot of this added autonomy that
principals enjoy there's a lot of
accountability measures that school
district central offices will set in
place to kind of keep tabs on principles
making make sure that they're really
putting their best foot forward and
making sure that their budget is aligned
with what the students need and also
making sure that they are publishing
students like success rates and that
type of thing so that parents can also
be informed which school they want to
send their kid to and they have more
information but some school districts
like Lisa was mentioning in Louisiana
the recovery school district are going
even further than we did student formula
I mean there they have a complete market
of fully autonomous charter schools that
compete to garner students and Louisiana
is the first or the recovery school
district was the first school district
that really employed this kind of new
model of redefining what a school
district is but there's actually other
school districts around the united
states that are also employing this kind
of market Mac and it like truly market
mechanism of attracting students to
schools some of those are Tennessee they
have an achievement School District it's
mop that's actually modeled after
Louisiana's recovery school district
it's a smaller scale the recovery school
district has 60 charter schools and 15
charter like schools Tennessee's
district only has 10 charters and then
16 excuse me 6 charter charter like
schools but it's still those schools
have complete autonomy over how they
function how they operate they have
principles have autonomy over curriculum
and the schools are funded on a per
pupil basis also Charlotte North
Carolina they're working on you
a project lift its project leadership
and investment for transformation where
there'll be nine schools that will be
fully autonomous and then there's a few
others like Kansas City and then one
that I think is most notable is in
Birmingham Alabama Alabama doesn't even
have charter school law and in 2013 was
the first year that they actually
implemented to choice programs so before
that they didn't really have a lot to
offer the kids or their their parents
and so they actually in Birmingham
they've actually not only has the state
overall adopted two more choice programs
but in Birmingham they're trying to put
together legislation and get the
Birmingham School Board of Education has
already sent this to the state to try
and create their own kind of recovery
type school district where there's
charter like autonomy although they
can't have charter schools but they're
trying to implement that in a state that
until 2013 really had very little choice
at all so it's I mean what Lisa and I
have been kind of showing with all these
different school choice initiatives than
pushing that has been pushed forward
that districts are really hearing out a
lot of parents and there's understanding
that the need for school choice and
there's a huge demand for school choice
and it's really interesting that
districts are being very innovative
regardless of the status quo regardless
of the laws that they have in place in
their state they're finding new ways to
really provide this that school choice
to parents and their communities overall
but that'll kind of turn it over at it
Katherine and she'll talk about
technology in school system I always
feel like school choice week it's like
one of the rare occasions where we have
an event a reason that's mostly good
news like we tend to we tend to hold
these events that are like the economy
is a disaster the political process is a
disaster our president is a disaster all
the alternatives to our president or
disasters
so it's really nice to have this event
where it's like everyone puts on your
cute yellow scarves and we're like
school choice is winning but it is which
is which is which is great news I mean
we've got we've had kind of a slew
statistics about successes but um you
know even just some very very basic
numbers like 42 states plus DC allow the
creation of public charter schools right
that is something that was just
completely unthinkable you know 10 20
years ago 21 states allow students to
attend whatever school they want
regardless of their home district every
state has magnet schools i mean this is
this is huge huge progress 23 states
plus DC have vouchers or opportunity
scholarships the list goes on and on i
just want to kind of briefly make the
case for for throwing into those lists
for adding to that pile kind of online
learning blended learning and and the
ways that the technology are adding to
to school choice to educational choice
right because this term school choice is
super powerful and it's it's made tons
of it's made tons of headway because
everybody likes choice see for instance
that giant stack of reason anthologies
titled choice but but it's not just
school choice right it's actually
educational choice people are physically
attending schools where they're getting
vastly different education from each
other or they're not attending school at
all thanks to online learning now the
way that you know that online learning
belongs on this list is that all the
same people who really hate school
choice also really hate online learning
right so like any any of the rhetoric
that you hear about charters and
vouchers about pipeline oh right
privatized or someone's making money off
this which I can't possibly be good
because it's a very important thing you
know and people shouldn't make money on
important things you hear that about
about schools you also hear that about
online education and you hear the same
thing about cream skimming right well
the only reason the numbers for online
education look good if they look good is
because motivated students and parents
are there and you know so we should
disregard any successes on that basis
you know Diane Ravitch is like the the
purse
to check in with on this and she hates
online learning just as much as she
hates charter schools and and voucher so
you know you're on to something good
there when Diane I ravaged kind of loses
her mind but I you know I think there's
there's this kind of idea that you know
we owe kids who have the worst lot more
choice right and this is here there's
always with vouchers in DC which is art
with the well factors too but charter
schools in DC which is very charter
school rich there's still almost no
charter schools located in this
neighborhood for instance and there are
a couple but most of the charter schools
are located in Anacostia where where the
need is the greatest and while that is I
think a good thing and has helped make
the case for charters you know one way I
think to think about online learning and
how that fits into this is to just say
you know before what we were trying to
do was give kids access to at least as
good as the average right we were just
trying to take kids out of the really
really really shitty schools that they
were stuck in because of their zip code
and just give them something that's okay
and and I think what I'll in learning
can do and is doing is you know
everybody should have access to the
stuff that rich people used to have that
rich people use to the only ones to
access and this is true in all areas of
life right you know air conditioning
right i mean we don't you know any any
kind of medical care right ideally the
way that markets work is that we take
the special expensive thing that rich
people used to get and pretty soon
everybody gets it at a reasonable price
and you know when you think about
something like probably the biggest name
in online learning which is khan academy
which everyone is sort of um it's a
private tutor it's a good private tutor
and that is something that really
matters I for instance in high school
was a terrible private tutor you know my
school had this nice volunteer program
and the kids in the AP classes are
supposed to help tutor the kids who
needed extra help and I am sure that I
setback this poor woman in her french
lessons probably like two or three years
just like I you know I made up answers
when I did
no them and are you just a complete
disaster I think that's that's something
that's worth noting right that one of
the things that online learning and and
video lessons can do is they can bring
the best lesson to everyone that the
best doesn't have to be an exclusive
commodity anymore and you know when you
think about Khan it's 52 employees right
it's 52 employees and they've
administered 350 million online lessons
they have 10 million unique users every
month all of those people are getting
basically the best four minute tutorial
about how to add fractions that you
could possibly get and that's that
doesn't always show up in the debates
about school choice and that phenomenon
doesn't always show up when we're trying
to capture you know well how can we help
kids in Louisiana how can we help kids
in New Orleans who were at the very
bottom of the pile you know one answer
is innovation and charters and just
letting them physically move around from
building to building and let you know
entrepreneurs open new schools but it
may also be that you know the sort of
state lines and the city lines and the
district lines are becoming just as
irrelevant as the you know school
boundaries have already become and I
think that would be a truly awesome
development and I guess just really
quickly I would tack on to this the fact
that you know technology is making
charters work better and that's
something that's easy to overlook
charters have to be leaner and meaner
charters are doing you know they have
this this set amount of money per kid or
however it is that the different schools
near the different states do the formula
but they don't have lots of benefits
like physical plant they don't have lots
of benefits like maintenance that's paid
for by the by a separate budget item
that means you have to figure out a way
to teach kids more for less money and an
online learning is a huge way to do that
blended learning like in rocket ship
Academy like in the Kip and power
schools in Los Angeles which I know lisa
has done some work with you know these
are places where they are they had their
budgets cut and they said we were going
to figure out how to put you know ten
kids in front of computer
get more out of those kids than the
traditional public schools are able to
do and you know I think I think that the
the idea that school choices at least in
part about escape is just about getting
away from the worst and we all know that
we use our computers for escapism right
we we dive in there and we go to
different worlds and we learn about
stuff the way otherwise wouldn't have
access to and we meet people who
otherwise couldn't meet and I think you
know the idea that that we should send
kids to buildings even better buildings
even you know charter school buildings
that are not dangerous or that are not
depressing and still ask them to be
offline for six hours a day it's kind of
going about it all wrong and I think
charters are bringing in school choices
bringing more technology into the
classrooms and that can only be to the
good
you